we have laws that are the worst anywhere
in the world as far as stopping people
from coming in but with that being said
went down over 40% of border crossings
we've been able to do that was President
Trump talking about the illegal
immigration crisis but there is
something you don't often hear about a
legal immigration crisis thanks to chain
migration the White House has released
figures showing that chain migration
check this out is responsible for 7.8
million immigrants who've come to the
United States in the last decades like
the size of New York City right that's a
vast majority of roughly ten point eight
million legal immigrants who've come
here again since 2008 so chain migration
allows newly naturalized citizens to
bring in essentially unlimited number of
foreign relatives to the country even
often distant relatives here to discuss
this is Ron ovitch a low acting Tibetan
Deputy Commissioner of US Customs and
Border Protection Ron's good to see you
thanks for being in here tonight
Thanks so we hear a lot about illegal
immigration but that part of the
immigration question I think a lot of
people forget about that what President
Trump has wanted to do from the very
beginning
as well as enforce the border we're
going to talk about is to have sensible
legal immigration policies that bring in
people they're gonna really add value to
our country
he certainly renewed the spirit of the
men and women in immigration Customs
Enforcement at CBP for us to do more on
the border there is a generous
immigration system but we need to do
more on the border and he's asked also
for the loopholes to be closed those are
really important things that we want to
see get done so Asylum fraud how
important would that be for you in the
men and women on the front lines doing
this job every day to get that Asylum
that those loopholes in that system that
allow so many people to come in now and
then just frankly sadly disappear we
have to get to a place where if people
come into the country illegally if they
have a due process that they have that
while they're still in custody so that
they're not abusing the system and
otherwise they don't flee and never show
up for the hearing which is what they
often do correct so that's why we're
asking for these loopholes to be closed
because we can do more on the border we
are doing better on the
border with this president we have new
wall going in we have the National Guard
deployments tell us about the wall
because I hear conflicting things about
the wall because we heard that I'm gonna
bust funded the wall but then we heard
it actually didn't fund the wall and the
president wasn't told the truth about
that
certainly not the wall that he wants so
we're installing the wall right now
Calexico California which is replacing
dilapidated fence that was on the border
now so we've got new capability going in
there
new capability in Santa Teresa New
Mexico replacing vehicle fence with
border wall we have projects and
planning underway for South Texas and
San Diego for replacement in California
so all of those are going to be improved
conditions for our agents to work in a
safer border environment and more
technology to go along with it you know
I had over the years interviewed so many
Border Patrol agents and customs agents
who were so demoralized because they
want to do their job and they felt like
and I'm not trying to get you political
here but under the previous
administration they were kind of being
held back or even sometimes vilified
unfairly tell me about just the general
you referenced it briefly but the
general mood of the people who have to
do this job and oftentimes it is not a
safe job it is a very difficult job they
take enormous risks and they want to be
successful so the renewed focus on
border security has been very important
for us so adding capability doing better
doing it in a safer environment and
giving what the American people want
they want to say for border and now we
have this opportunity with this
president to try to get more of that
capability down there so that we can do
our jobs tell me what you all need
Congress to do you have Republicans in
charge of the House Republicans in
charge of the Senate and a Republican
president who made border enforcement a
primary focus of his administration so
we want them to prioritize investments
that we can add capabilities so the
border wall system we're trying to hire
agents we need to do that and we also
need these loopholes close we need the
loop to be closed on the asylum system
we need to have a way to hold people
when they come into the country until
their time to be removed once they have
the due process so if we can do all of
those things at the same time we'll have
a much safer border fewer people will
try to we'll try to take that dangerous
journey that's what we're asking we have
we have people in Congress now number
mostly more moderate liberal Republicans
trying to push a new amnesty they call
it this it was a technical way of
getting a lot of bills on the floor I
would have to go into it but would
amnesty or the dangling the prospect of
amnesty at this point as we approach the
summer months
would that make your job easier or more
difficult I don't believe so what we
need to do is I don't believe what which
one I don't think it more difficult I
don't think it'll make it easier I'll be
more difficult would it not like the
summer of 2014 when there was a
possibility of amnesty with Boehner and
Cantor and all those guys and you had a
big wave of unaccompanied minors
crossing the border remember that summer
the part else will look for ways to
exploit the way the system is working
now so closing the loopholes and adding
the capability in these investments
border wall the National Guard giving us
more technology on the board or hiring
agents that's what we need to do how
about the prosecutors at the border how
about the fact that you need these
immigration judges down there again they
have they have like 6,000 more personnel
I believe immigration officials and
judges down there that's what the
president I believe is getting but when
you have tens of thousands of people
crossing in a three and four week period
I mean you need more than that do you
not so the Justice Department is
stepping up they're adding resources
there they went to the hundred percent
prosecution so the Secretary has
directed us to refer all people who
cross the border illegally for
prosecution and so we're starting to
ramp up those capabilities as well what
we've learned over the years if you
apply a consequence to people when
they're doing an illegal activity yeah
you'll get less of it yeah heaven forbid
you actually have consequences for
illegal activity keep us updated because
I think the American people need to hear
from you directly you guys are doing the
job and we need to hear from you
directly what you need there's no
politics here what you need to get the
job done period will you keep us
informed happy to do that we really
appreciate it